Good morning Hank; it’s Monday. On Thursday
I’m going to be reading and signing in Plainfield,
Indiana, and then on Friday I’m moving to
the Netherlands for two months. I keep meaning
to mention to you that I’m moving to the
Netherlands for two months, but there is so
much going on! In a related story, the sound
that my anxiety makes is AAAAAAAAHHHHH!
And Hank, when I get stressed out I like to
play “Google auto-fill once again proves
that people are weird”. Hank, today I’m
going to answer the questions people ask Google
the most beginning “Is my b...?”
“Is my boyfriend gay?” Huh. I wonder if
“is my hus” stars similarly. Yes. What
about “is my wife”-- Nope, the first two
questions we have about our wives: are they
cheating, and what is their tax status? And
people say men aren’t romantic, Hank. Similarly,
homosexuality never comes up if you Google
“is my g”, all we want to know is that
our girlfriends are not cheating, not crazy,
and that our guns are not stolen. Off topic,
Hank, but the Venn diagrammatical intersection
between people who Google “is my girlfriend
cheating?” and people who Google “is my
gun stolen"? Worrisome.
Right, but about your possibly gay boyfriend,
two things. First, human sexuality is not
an either/or proposition, and trying to deny
its complexity is going to make both you and
your partner miserable. Secondly, let me submit
that this is not a question for Google. It
is a question for your boyfriend!
“Is my baby sick?” Listen, I know why
you’re asking Google this question. You’re
asking because the alternative is to put a
thermometer in your baby’s rectum, and your
baby will look up at you like “I am not
enjoying this!” and you’ll be like “You
know what, this isn’t my idea of a fun Thursday
night either!” and then your baby’ll be
like “But I am incapable of empathy!”
But it is my sad duty to inform you that while
Google can take a picture of your house, it
cannot stick a thermometer inside your baby’s
bottom. That’s your job, sorry. If your
baby’s under six weeks old and has a temperature
over a hundred and one, call your doctor immediately.
“Is my boyfriend cheating on me?” Yes.
“Is my baby teething?” Yes.
“Is my boyfriend losing interest?” Well
yeah, otherwise, why would he be cheating
on you?
“Is my boyfriend cheating on me quiz?”
You want a quiz? Okay, here is your quiz:
Did you just Google "is my boyfriend cheating
on me?" If you answered yes, he may or may
not be cheating on you, but there is definitely
a problem! It may be that your boyfriend is
cheating on you, or that he’s untrustworthy,
or that you’re incapable of trust, or that
you don’t believe that you’re good enough
to deserve his monogamous affection. It may
be that you feel undervalued or that he feels
smothered, but something has gone wrong that
Google cannot answer! You have to talk to
your boyfriend. And sometimes those conversations
will result in breaking up, and I know that
breaking up sucks, but it is better than having
to Google “is my husband cheating”!
“Is my baby a boy or a girl?” Probably
a boy. I mean, it’s a slight probably, but
I’m going with it.
“Is my boyfriend cheating?” Come on, seriously?
We just went over this!
“Is my blood pressure high?” Probably,
you’re very anxious about your boyfriend,
and that cannot be good for your health! Ideally
you want your blood pressure to be in the
green or the yellow, not in the orange or
the red. Yet another example, Hank, of why
it’s good to be green.
And lastly, “Is my baby sleeping too much?”
Okay first off, if your baby is eating enough
and gaining weight, your baby is not sleeping
too much. Second off, don’t take this personally,
but I hate you.
So Nerdfighters with boyfriends and girlfriends,
talk to each other! Hank, don’t forget to
be awesome. I gotta go upstairs and pack;
I will see you on Wednesday!